do you think experts can save us is
there such thing as expertise and
experts in something how do you know if
you've achieved it I think it's it's
important to acknowledge up front that
this there's something paradoxical about
how we relate to to Authority especially
within science
um and I don't think that Paradox is
going away and it's just it doesn't have
to be confusing it's just and it's not
it's not truly a paradox it's just like
there are different moments in time
so
it is true to say
that
within science or within a within
rationality generally I mean just
whenever you're making having a
fact-based discussion about anything
it is true to say that the truth or
falsity of a statement
does not even slightly depend on the
credentials of the person making the
statement right so it doesn't matter if
you're a Nobel Laureate you can be wrong
right the thing you could either the
last sentence you spoke could be total
right
and it's also possible for someone who's
deeply uninformed to be right about
something or in order to be right for
the wrong reasons right or someone just
gets lucky or someone or or and they're
they're middling cases where you have
like a a backyard astronomer who's got
no credentials but he just loves
astronomy and he's got a telescope and
it's he's spent a lot of time looking at
the nice guy
and he discovers a comment that no one
else has seen you know not even
the professional expert astronomers
um
I mean I gotta think that happens less
and less now but but some version of
that keeps happening and it may always
keep happening in every area of
expertise right
um
so
it's true that truth is orthogonal to
the reputational concerns we have among
Apes who are talking about the truth
um
but it is also true that most of the
time
real experts are much more reliable than
frauds or people who are not experts
right you know so and expertise really
is a thing right and when it's you know
when you're flying an airplane in a
storm
you don't want just randos come into the
cockpit saying listen I've got a new
idea about how to you know how we should
tweak these controls right you want
someone who's a trained pilot and and
that training gave them something right
it gave them a set of competences and
intuitions and they they know what all
those dials and switches do right and I
don't right I shouldn't be flying that
plane
um
and so when things really matter
you know and put in this at 30 000 feet
in a storm sharpens this up
we want real experts to be in charge
right and
we are at 30 000 feet a lot of the time
on a lot of issues right and whether
they're public health issues whether
it's issue whether it's a geopolitical
emergency like Ukraine I mean climate
change
I mean just pick your pick your topic
um
there are real problems
and the clock is rather often ticking
and their Solutions are non-obvious
right and and so expertise is a thing
and deferring to experts much of the
time
makes a lot of sense it's at minimum it
it
prevents
you know spectacular errors of
incompetence and and uh
just uh you know foolhardiness but it
even in in the case of some or where
you're talking about someone I mean
people like ourselves who are like we're
well educated we we're not the worst
possible candidates for you know the
dunning-kruger effect when we're going
into a new area where we're not experts
we're fairly alert to the possibility
that we don't you know it's not as
simple as things seem at first and we
don't you know we don't know how our
tools translate to this new area we can
be fairly circumspect but we're also
because we're well educated
we can work and we're pretty quick
studies we can learn a lot of things
pretty fast and we can begin to play a
language game that sounds fairly expert
right and
in that case
the the invitation to do your own
research right is in once when times are
good
I view as an invitation to waste your
time pointlessly right when times are
good now the truth is times are not all
that good right and we have the
the ongoing public display of failures
of expertise we have experts who are
obviously corrupted by bad incentives
we've got experts who you know
perversely won't admit they were wrong
when they in fact you know are
demonstrated to be wrong we've got
institutions that have been captured by
political ideology that's not truth
tracking and this this whole woke
um
uh encroachment into really every place
you know whether it's universities or
science journals or government or it's
just like that is that has been
genuinely deranging
um
so there's a lot going on that where
experts and and the Very concept of
expertise has seemed to discredit itself
but the reality is that there is a
massive difference when anything matters
when there's anything to know about
anything there's a massive difference
most of the time between someone who has
really done the work to understand that
domain and someone who hasn't and
if I get sick or someone close to me
gets sick
you know I I have a PhD in Neuroscience
right so I can read a medical journal
article and understand a lot of it right
and I you know so I'm just fairly
conversant with you know medical
terminology
and I understand his methods and I I'm
alert to the difference because I've you
know because in Neuroscience I've spent
hours and hours in journal clubs you
know diagnosing you know the different
and analyzing the difference between
good and bad studies
I'm I'm alert to the difference between
good and bad studies and in medical
journals right and I understand that bad
studies can get published and you know
Etc
uh and and experiments can be poorly
designed
I'm alert to all of those things but
when I get sick or when someone close to
me gets sick I don't pretend to be a
doctor right I've got no clinical
experience I don't go down the rabbit
hole on Google for days at a stretch
trying to become a doctor much less a
specialist in the domain of problem that
has been visited upon me or my family
right so if someone close to me gets
cancer I don't pretend to be an
oncologist I don't go out and start I
don't start reading you know in journals
of oncology and try to really get up to
speed as an oncologist because it's it's
not it's
one is a one is a bad and potential and
very likely misleading
use of my time right and it and it's
if I decide if I had if I had a lot of
Runway if I decided okay it's really
important for me to know everything I
can at this point I want to I know
someone's going to get cancer
I may not go back to school and become
an oncologist but what I want to do is I
want to know everything I can know about
cancer right so I'm going to take the
next four years and spend most of my
time on cancer okay I could do that
right I still think that's a waste of my
time uh I still think at the end of even
at the end of those four years I'm not
going to be the best person to to form
intuitions about what to do in the face
of the next cancer that I have to
confront
um
I'm still going to want a better
oncologist than I've become to tell me
what he or she would do if they were in
my shoes or in the shoes of you know my
family member I'm gonna you know I'm
what I'm what I'm not Advocate I'm not
advocating a
a blind trust and Authority like if you
get cancer
and you're talking to one oncologist and
they're recommending some course of
treatment by all means get a second
opinion get a third opinion right but it
matters that those opinions are coming
from real experts and not from you know
Robert Kennedy Jr you know who's telling
you that you know you got it because you
got a you know a vaccine right it's like
it's it's just it it there's we're
swimming in a sea of misinformation
where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who sh who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no there is no
scenario in which you should be getting
your opinion about vaccine safety or or
climate change or
uh the war in Ukraine or anything else
that we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like it
like like she she's not a relevant
expert on any of those topics and what's
more she doesn't seem to care right and
and she's living in a culture that has
that has
Amplified that not caring into a
business model an effective business
model right so it's just it's um and
then there's something very trumpy and
about all that or like that's that's the
pro the problem is is the culture it's
not these specific individuals
um so so the Paradox here is that
expertise is a real thing
and we defer to it a lot as a as a
labor-saving device as just as and just
based on the the
the the reality that it's very hard to
be a polymath right and specialization
is a thing right and so there are people
who specialize in a very narrow topic
they know more about that topic than the
next guy no matter how smart that that
guy or gal is uh
and and that those differences matter
but it's also true
that when you're talking about facts
sometimes
the the the the best experts are wrong
the scientific consensus is wrong you
get a a sea change in the thinking of a
whole field because one person who's an
outlier for whatever reason decides okay
I'm uh you know I'm gonna prove this
point and they prove it right so
somebody like uh
the Doctor Who uh believed that that
stomach ulcers were not due to stress
but were due to to um H pylori
infections right so he just drank a vial
of H pylori bacteria and and prove that
and then quickly got an ulcer and
convinced the field that that at minimum
H pylori was involved in in that process
okay so yes everyone was wrong that
doesn't disprove the reality of
expertise it doesn't disprove the
utility of relying on Experts most of
the time especially in an emergency
especially when the clock is ticking
especially when you're you know you're
in this particular cockpit and you only
have one chance to land this plane right
you want the real pilot uh at the
controls but there's just a few things
to say
so one you mentioned this example with
cancer and doing your own research there
there are several things that are
different about
our particular time in history one doing
your own research has become more and
more effective because you can read the
internet made information a lot more
accessible so you can read a lot of
different meta-analyzes you can read
blog posts that
described you exactly the flaws and the
different papers they make up the meta
meta-analyzes they and you can read a
lot of those blog posts that are
conflicting with each other and you can
take that information in and in a short
amount of time you can start to make
um
good faith interpretations for example I
don't know I don't want to overstate
things but
um if you suffer from depression for
example
then there you could go to an expert and
a doctor that prescribes you some
medication
but you could also challenge some of
those ideas and seeing like what are the
different medications what are the
different side effects what are the
different solutions to depression all
that kind of stuff and I think
depression is just a really difficult
problem that's very
um I don't want to Again State incorrect
things but I think it's
there's a lot of variability of what
depression really means so it being
introspective about the type of
depression you have and the different
possible solutions you have just doing
your own research as a first step before
approaching a doctor or as you have
multiple opinions could be very
beneficial in that case
now that's depression that's something
that's been studied for a very long time
with a new pandemic that's affecting
everybody
that it's uh you know with the airplane
uh equated to like 911 or something like
the new emergency just happened and
everybody every expert in the world is
publishing on it and talking about it so
doing your own research there could be
exceptionally effective in asking
questions and then there's a difference
between experts virologists and it's
actually a good question who is exactly
the expert in a pandemic yeah but
there's the actual experts doing the
research and Publishing stuff
and then there's the communicators of
that expertise and the question is uh if
the communicators are flawed
to to a degree we're doing your own
research is actually the more effective
way to figure out policies and solutions
because you're not competing with
experts you're competing with the
communicators of expertise that could be
who CDC in the case of the pandemic or
politicians or political type of science
figures like Anthony fauci there's a
question there
of
the effectiveness of doing your research
your own research in that context
and the competing
forces there incentives that you've
mentioned is you can be become quite
popular by being contrarian by saying
everybody's lying to you all the
authorities aligned to you all the
institutions aligned to you so those are
the waters you're swimming in but I
think doing your own research in that
kind of context could be quite effective
let me be clear I'm not saying
you shouldn't do any research right I'm
not saying that you shouldn't be
informed about an issue I'm not saying
you shouldn't read articles on on
whatever the topic is and yet yes if I
got cancer or someone close to me got
cancer I I I probably would read more
about cancer than I've read thus far
about cancer and I've read some
um
so I'm not I'm not making a virtue of
ignorance
and of blind obedience to Authority and
I again I recognize that authorities can
discredit themselves or they can be
wrong
uh they can be wrong even when they had
that when there's no discredit there's
just there's a lot we don't understand
about the the nature of the world
um
but still this this vast Gulf between
truly informed opinion and
exists it always exists and
um and conspiracy thinking is
rather often you know most of the time
the species of but it's not
always wrong right there are real
conspiracies and there there really are
just awful
Corruptions of you know but born of bad
incentives within our you know our
scientific processes within institutions
and again we've mentioned a lot of these
things in passing but you know what what
woke political ideology did to
Scientific communication during the
pandemic was awful and it was really
corrosive of public trust especially on
the on the right
um for understandable reasons and it was
just it was crazy some of the things
that were being said and still is
and these cases are all different so you
take depression but we just don't know
enough about depression for you know
anyone to be that confident about
anything right and there are many
different modalities in which to
interact with it is a problem right so
there's Pharmaceuticals have whatever
promise they have but there's there's
certainly reason to be concerned that
they don't work well for everybody and
and
uh yeah I mean that's it's obvious they
don't work well for everybody but they
do work for some people
um
but again depression is a
multi-factorial problem and they're
they're different levels at which to to
influence it and they're you know the
things like meditation they're things
like just life changes and
and uh
you know one of the reverse things about
depression is that when you're depressed
all of the things that would be good for
you to do or precisely things you don't
want to do you don't have any energy to
socialize you don't want to get things
done you don't want to exercise you
don't and
um all of those things if you've got
those up and running they do make you
feel better in you know in the aggregate
but um the reality is that they're you
know there are clinical level
depressions that are so bad that it's
just we just don't have good tools for
them and it's not enough to tell there's
no life change someone's gonna gonna
Embrace that it's going to be an obvious
remedy for that
um
the pain I mean pandemics are are
obviously a complicated problem but I
would consider it much simpler than
depression in terms of
you know what's on the menu to be this
chosen among the various choices just
less multifactorial the logic by which
you would make those choices yeah so
it's like we have a virus we have a new
virus
it's some version of bad you know it's
human transmissible
we're still catching up we're catching
up to every aspect of we don't know how
it spreads we don't know how how
effective masks are at a certain point
we knew it was respiratory but we knew
it but yeah and whether it's spread by
fomites or like all that we were
confused about a lot of things and we're
still confused it's been a moving Target
this whole time and it's been changing
this whole time and our responses to it
have been
you know we we ramped up the vaccines as
quickly as we as we could but you know
too quick for some not as not quick
enough for others we could have done
human challenge trials and got them out
more quickly with with better data
um and I think that's something we
should probably look at in the future
because you know that yeah to my eye
that would make ethical sense to do to
do challenge trials
um
but
and and so much of my concern about
covid I mean many people are confused
about my concern about covet my concern
about covet has
for much of the time not been narrowly
focused on covet itself how dangerous I
perceive covid to be as a as a illness
um
it has been for the longest time
even more concern about our ability to
respond to a truly scary pathogen next
time like what I I for you know outside
those initial months you know if give me
the first six months to be
quite worried about covid and and the
unraveling of society but in a supply of
toilet paper you want to secure a steady
supply of toilet paper but beyond that
initial period
when we had a sense of what we were
dealing with and we had every hope that
the vaccines are actually going to work
and we're getting and we knew we were
getting those vaccines in short order
right beyond that and and we had and and
we knew just how dangerous the illness
was and how dangerous it wasn't
um
for years now I've just been worrying
about this as a failed dress rehearsal
for something much worse right I think
what we prove to ourselves at this
moment in history is that
we have built informational tools that
we do not know how to use to and we have
made ourselves we've basically enrolled
all of human society into a
psychological experiment
that is
deranging us and making it
virtually impossible to solve
coordination problems that we absolutely
have to solve next time when things are
worse